Israel ordering a Complete Siege of the
Gods of strip as they rain bombs down on
the Hamas Terrace Trey in has been on
the ground in Israel all day and
literally had to take cover multiple
times stay with us here get down just
everyone just go flat we don't have time
everyone's just laying flat on the
ground here we've got to take
cover you hear that explosion that's an
interception another time they're
they're trying to overwhelm the Iron
Dome again I can see them coming off the
Goa STP from multiple locations
just Trey as usual you're in the thick
of things I hope you're safe and well uh
what's the
latest Greg good afternoon right now we
are seeing the Israeli military strike
the Gaza Strip once again since Saturday
afternoon they've started to Target Gaza
following that bloody massacre against
innocent Israelis more than 900 people
were killed at the hands of Palestinian
militants who infiltrated into Israel
tonight Israel is preparing for a ground
invasion of Gaza today throughout the
day we saw tanks and apcs thousands of
Israeli soldiers and yav Galant the
country's defense minister saying that
300,000 reservists have been called up
and showed up preparing to fight and
enter Gaza all of this taking place as
Rocket fire continues into Southern and
Central Israel the cities of Jerusalem
and Tel Aviv were targeted today and now
this question of whether or not Israel
will face a multi-front conflict with
the possibility of a new front opening
with
Lebanon Trey I wanted to ask you about
one of the tactics it seems that of
course this is Modern Warfare we did see
this with Isis as well but utilizing
social media in order to be to to
prosecute the attack and
I was learning a little bit more today
about how some of these terrorists would
take the victim's
phone film what they were doing to them
and then post that to their social media
feeds and I you've covered many
conflicts but this seems to me a little
bit of a different tactic and a a
terrible one but at least it
does give everyone a chance to see what
this evil really looks
like yeah the militants wanted to
inflict the maximum amount of Terror
against the civilian population here
they went into people's homes and
slaughtered women and children who
couldn't fight back like cowards these
are Isis wannabes when they took over
different military bases along the
border rather than conducting an
operation like a country would with a
military they beheaded soldiers they
dragged bodies through the streets of
Gaza and then captured people to take
into the tunnels under underneath the
Gaza Strip a lot of this for the
propaganda of the group to inflict that
fear into the hearts and minds of the
Israeli people and they were able to do
that but what they didn't understand is
that by doing that they would mobilize
an entire country against them and that
is what is taking place today there are
hundreds of thousands who have been
called up to serve in the Army those who
are not serving are volunteering at
hospitals preparing for more injured
people to be brought in and even
restaurant owners they're bringing food
to the Gaza border to soldiers and to
civilians everyone is pitching in where
they can because they understand while
it has been a bloody and violent past
two days this could and likely will just
be the beginning of a massive ground war
in the Middle East Trey uh Charlie HT
here uh amid all of your amazing
reporting uh one of the most haunting
details was your description of uh these
Hamas terrorists going house to house
and
uh finding families cowering in safe
rooms and if they couldn't break down
the door to get to the families they
would just light the entire house on
fire do you have any sense of how many
people died that way and is that a
tactic that we've ever seen
before so the majority of people were
killed when these militants entered
these communities along the border this
is a tactic that is unheard of in Modern
Warfare such an extremist way to
slaughter innocent people and again that
was their way of conducting themselves
in southern Israel they're still in the
country holding territory according to
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu but they were going from house
to house killing as many people as they
could and today we got new information
from one of the communities called b
along the border and it's a community
with about a thousand people that live
there and more than a 100 bodies were
recovered today 10% of their population
killed at the hands of these militants
and again these were not people that
were on a military base they were not
engaging them in a gun battle they were
women and children I we have seen
graphic graphic imagery on Telegram and
these messaging apps we've seen the
videos and the photos published by these
militants and these organizations in
Gaza of children four and five yearolds
that were killed in their homes and
they're celebrating it in Gaza and it is
really motivating the Israeli public and
the soldiers that we've spoken to at the
border to go into Gaza and is as Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu put it
to destroy
Hamas hey Trey it's Jesse H tarab here
thank you so much for joining us and for
your incredible reporting the last
couple of days I'm curious if you could
shed some more light on what a ground
war would look like you mentioned that
this would spread to The Wider Middle
East is there expectation of boots on
the ground from other nations and um
where do you think the coalitions will
end up going we've seen Saudi backing
off a little bit um in terms of their
support for heras versus Israel um but
yeah what do what do you think it's
going to look
like so a ground war in Gaza is going to
be incredibly difficult the Israelis
have entered Gaza before and they've
held territory there and Gaza is one of
the most densely populated areas on
Earth there are 1.9 million people that
live there and it's a 25 mile strip of
land it's anywhere from three to seven
miles wide and so they're going to enter
the Gaza Strip and they're going to be
immediately engaged by Hamas and Islamic
Jihad militants along with other smaller
Palestinian factions and it will be
incredibly difficult because they're
fighting on their Turf and they're
fighting an urban battle that will
involve RPGs Small Arms fire The
Continuous rocket fire into the Border
communities and deeper into Israel and
so that's part of what the ground war
would look like on the southern front
and there will be a constant Insurgency
against the Israeli forces if they
decide to stay there for a long time
even civilians who support the cause of
Hamas could get involved in that
fighting now on the northern border a
ground war would be much more
challenging we have been into the
Hezbollah tunnels along the border
between Lebanon and Israel and the
infrastructure there is more significant
the Weaponry is more significant off in
the distance now I can hear those
Israeli air strikes continuing along the
Gaza Strip but when it comes to Lebanon
we've seen the classified intelligence
the former Defense Minister Benny Gant
showed it to me himself the Israelis had
mapped out where Hezbollah keeps their
Precision guided missiles and the
rockets all of them are aimed at Israel
and there are thousands of different
positions and so the war with Lebanon
and the war with Hezbollah is really the
larger 30,000 foot view concern for
Israel Trey Janine pero here you know
the Hamas um and I prefer calling them
terrorists and not militants but they've
indicated that they will uh execute one
hostage for every Israeli strike um
moving forward I don't know and and
maybe you do how Israel will handle this
and and there's also a second part of
this if there is a war in the Goan
Heights the northern border at you know
where Lebanon is uh do other countries
then get involved how is Israel in a
position to defend herself uh especially
since I'm hearing that the Iron Dome uh
is kind of uh it's kind of being
stretched in terms of its strength
because they're shooting missiles
missiles some of which are duds that
start to wear down the Dome so that
there is this concerted effort again in
this kind of coordinated militaristic
way that they're handling this where
Israel is truly on the
defensive yeah this is part of the issue
is that they're dealing with two
separate fronts and two different groups
of Fighters and already today Hezbollah
militants tried to cross into Israel and
were engaged in a firefight with the
Israelis so there is an understanding
that if this multi-front war erupts at
the level that Israel believes it could
it could drag the entire region into
this fight and when it comes to other
countries involvement it's part of the
reason the United States is moving an
aircraft carrier closer to Israel they
want to send a message to Hamas Islamic
Jihad and Hezbollah that Israel has
support from its allies and that's
really a critical part of this story as
things develop here in southern
Israel Trey thanks so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else